>> Tucker: NIGHT FOUR, THE FINAL
NIGHT OF THE REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
CONVENTION JUST MOMENTS AGO.
THE OPERA WILL GAVE TO SPEECHES,
THEN THE PRESIDENT CARRYING ALL
OF IT HERE ON FOX, STAY TUNED.
RYE OLTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR
THREE MONTHS, RAISE THE QUESTION
WHY DO WE HAVE POLICE?
WE HIRE COPS TO CLEAN UP THE THE
MESSES THE REST OF US CREATE.
PEOPLE DON’T GET MARRIED BEFORE
THEY HAVE KIDS AD AND THEIR
FATHERLESS SONS TURN VIOLENT.
BIG BUSINESS OFFSHORE BLUE
CALENDAR JOB AND COMMUNITIES
COLLAPSE.
IT IS THE POLICE WHO DEAL WITH
THE CONSEQUENCE.
NOT ALL COPS ARE GOOD AT THEIR
JOB.
BUT IN THE END THE BIG PROBLEMS
ARE NOT THEIR FAULT.
MOST ARE WORKING CLASS GUYS
DOING THEIR BEST.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THEM WORKING
CLASS GUYS ARE DONALD TRUMP’S
BAIT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HATES THEM
FOR THAT PARTICULARLY IN AN
ELECTION YEAR.
TO NEUTRALIZE THEM THE LEFT HAS
CONSTRUCTED A BASELESS BUT
ELABORATE LIE DESIGNED TO
CONVINCE YOU THAT THE POLICE ARE
THE REAL PROBLEM IN THE COUNTRY.
AMAZINGLY AN AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE FALLEN FOR IT.
THAT’S WHY THERE ARE NO COPS
AROUND ANY MORE.
THE RESULT OF THAT, CHAOS.
DOZENS DEAD.
KIDS IN THE STREETS WITH GUNS.
AMERICA’S CITIES ON FIRE.
WHY DID THAT HAPPEN?
THE LEFT NEUTERED THE POLICE.
NONE OF THESE CITIES LOOK LIKE
THIS THREE MONTHS AGO, NOT UNTIL
THEY DID.
THIS THE CONSEQUENCES ARE THEIR
FAULT.
NOT YOUR FAULT, NOT THE FAULT OF
THE POLICE, THEY’RE THE FAULT OF
THE ACADEMIC LEFT THAT MADE THIS
POSSIBLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
KENOSHA, WISCONSIN IS THE LATEST
PLACE FOR IT TO HAPPEN.
HERE’S SOME OF WHAT HAPPENED
THIS WEEK.
[SCREAMING]
OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD!
[GUNFIRE]
>> Tucker: WHO DID THAT?
WHO TURNED A NICE LITTLE TOWN
LIKE KENOSHA, WISCONSIN INTO A
HELLSCAPE WHERE 17-YEAR-OLDS ARE
SHOOTING PEOPLE?
YOU DIDN’T DO THAT, THE COPS
DIDN’T DO THAT, THE LEFT DID
THAT.
THEY DESTROYED THAT CITY.
THEY ABETTED THE VIOLENCE YOU
SAW THE OTHER NIGHT, PERIOD.
THEY MADE THE COPS GO AWAY AND
WHEN THE COPS LEFT THEY FILLED
THE VOID.
PERIOD.
THEY’RE DENYING IT NOW BUT
THEY’RE LYING AS USUAL.
THE MEDIA DIDN’T WANT TO COVER
IT, MOST OF THEM DIDN’T.
THE JOB OF COVERING THE RIOTS
FELL TO WRITERS THAT ARE THERE,
JOINING US FOR AN UPDATE ON WHAT
HAPPENED IN KENOSHA.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT’S THE STATE.
CITY TONIGHT?
>> SO, I FLEW OUT OF KENOSHA
THIS MORNING.
LAST NIGHT, THERE WERE
GATHERINGS AT CURFEW.
IT WAS -- THEY HAD A MARCH, BUT
I DIDN’T SEE ANY CONFRONTATIONS
BETWEEN OFFICERS AND THE
PROTESTERS OR ON CIVILIANS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE SAW TUESDAY
NIGHT.
I THINK THAT WAS THE RESULT OF
TRUMP SENDING IN REINFORCEMENTS
AND BECAUSE PEOPLE SEEMINGLY ARE
MORE SCARED AFTER THE MULTIPLE
SHOOTERSINGS THAT HAPPENED ON
TUESDAY.
>> SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE,
TALKING TO OTHERS THERE, IT
LOOKS LIKE PREDICTABLY VIOLENCE
FILLED THE VOID LEFT BY
LEGITIMATE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THERE WAS NO ONE AROUND TO KEEP
ORDER, SO OF COURSE VIOLENCE
EXPLODED.
WAS THAT YOUR IMPRESSION BEING
THERE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED
MONDAY NIGHT.
THE RIOTING BROKE OUT ON SUNDAY.
INSTEAD OF ASKING FOR THE
REINFORCEMENTS, THE POLICE WERE
MOSTLY KEPT TO PROTECT THE
COUNTY COURTHOUSE AND THE
PRECINCT.
THAT LEFT THE REST OF THE
DOWNTOWN AREA AT THE MERCY OF
RIOTERS.
MULTIPLE BUILDINGS BURNED, A LOT
OF PROPERTY DAMAGED.
PARTICULARLY LIKE THE TARGET
PARKING LOTS FILLED WITH CARS.
THEN WE SAW IT AGAIN ON TUESDAY
NIGHT.
AND WE SAW IT, I WAS ONLY A FEW
FEET AWAY FROM THE SITE OF THE
SECOND SHOOTING.
IT WAS CHAOS, ANARCHY.
THIS IS REALLY THE RESULT OF
POOR LEADERSHIP AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVEL.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE IT IS.
IT LOOKED SCAREY AS HELL FROM
THE PICTURES, WAS IT?
>> AS YOU KNOW, TUCKER, I’VE
BEEN TRAVELING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, MINNEAPOLIS, SEATTLE,
PORTLAND.
AND THIS WAS SECOND TO
MINNEAPOLIS.
THE ONLY REASON WHY MINNEAPOLIS
IS NUMBER ONE BECAUSE OF HOW
LARGE SCALE.
MUCH, MUCH BIGGER SCALE.
BUT KENOSHA OF ALL PLACES TURNS
OUT TO BE NUMBER TWO IN MY BOOK
IN TERMS OF ANARCHY.
>> Tucker: OF ALL PLACES,
EXACTLY.